I think World War two is my favorite war
same here but I'll take it one further
world war two airplanes easily my top
obsession growing up I got high off
model glue red vials on Fame eyelets
fast forwarded Pearl Harbor for the
dogfights it was an addiction but where
I really got my fix flight Sims even
though I've been out of touch with
flight Sims lately war Thunder has
resurfaced all those memories it even
resurfaced smiled extreme 3d pro
joystick which I last use on the other
competing free-to-play combat flight
game World of Warplanes war planes is
fun but it's not a true flight sim only
with war thunder have I been able to hit
my early teen nerdgasm six hours in and
I absolutely adore this game without do
here's why war thunder does it better
first thing I did was check how many the
answer a buglar there are currently over
350 planes spread among five nations
almost tripling the warplanes line up
both games bring jets yet the Thunder
climbs higher throwing in four-engine
bombers and dive bombers like my
all-time favorite the u 87 Stuka i peed
a little once all those beasts the Stuka
was infamous for terrorizing its prey
with a siren screen which generated from
two propellers mounted on its landing
gear first time I heard that wail I got
chills
now was the sound effect essential and
adding the plane now but someone there
and knew it was speaking of attention to
detail Thunder opens up the history book
and lets you experience famous moments
from World War two offering a nice
relaxing break from the online arcade
startup campaign with Wake Island battle
the Bulge or maybe some dog fights in
the battle friend for heck rewrite the
history of Pearl Harbor Michael Bay did
it Oh war Thunder lets you authentically
experience history
but how do you want to play battle
britain fight for the fatherland or the
queen and pick a randomized mission that
says hey that sounds like me bombing
runs offer a slow suspenseful mission
yet you decide how slow eliminate those
shortcuts and start on the runway for
full realism or maybe you want to fly
into the unknown go on patrol on a
spitfire form up with some wingmen and
cruise the countryside looking for
trouble on a patrol run I found myself
googling at my boys behind me I got lost
in the moment and curiosity took over
what happens if I kill my engine well my
propeller stopping didn't surprise me
but what did was when it started
spinning faster or slower depending on
my pitch and speed landing gear down
flaps down soft touchdown applied brakes
fully aware that at any moment I can get
back into the air yeah I know this game
isn't breaking any grounds here but I
don't know it's just been a while since
I've been able to do that but landings
aren't always as rosy as we'd like
bogeys on your six tear your plane into
rags you're finished in Thunder when
your rudder gets shot up you'll feel it
and there's no health meter but a plane
diagram that roughly explains the damage
dealt what does one percent health even
mean
hitting 0% in war planes means one of
two things and uncontrollable death
spiral into the ground or you just
explode
in thunder there's a second chance your
goal now is to crash it pull off a safe
landing and you're rewarded for it same
goes for kills tripling the bomber isn't
good enough
following that kill guarantees you he
won't be dropping his payload this
mechanic is huge watching wings rip off
in a collision puts a grin on your face
every time climbing the research tree
takes time while also limiting you from
souping up every plane you unlock with
modifications thank God you can still
look pretty
where Warplanes restricts your creative
skins thunder releases in size and
position decals however you want yet
free to play burdens show up for both
games without spending a dime warplanes
rents your paint jobs for experience
points and fenders decent selection
limits to decals per plane but it
doesn't ground you there create a user
skin load it with any program like paint
or Photoshop and lose yourself these
choppers for example yes they are badass
but how about some eyes Google Images
BAM spiffy signature okay
pull back with an eraser and rub them up
with some wear and tear refresh legit
that honestly took me seven minutes how
about a raptor clever fire skulls on
this Stuka that's hot granted only you
can see your designs yet when you really
think about it you rarely see other
people's artwork anyway which is
probably a good thing
war thunder is an open beta with more to
come and it's not all planes party up
with tanks and down the road battleships
all within the same match World of
Warplanes oh that's not really fair
because I'd be talking about two other
games now wouldn't I for the record war
planes is fun just feels like an arcade
playing game war thunder on the other
hand takes the world war ii flight sim
seriously and that's all i've ever
wanted
you